want to take just a second here before I
go any further I just want to say that
and I've noticed this Andy you're just
looking great oh thank you very much
yeah I I have lost some weight recently
so yeah sure thank you you know that's
that's great cuz that it's a that's a
very hard thing to do you know not
really not since I got hissy fit Andy
what's hissy fit oh it's just the best
fitness app ever roll a commercial Billy
what commercial Andy but the commercial
for hissy fit did you send this one I
don't know I mean just get one off you
two okay give us a minute do I look like
I have a minute
I'm on national television for Christ's
sake : is waiting come on you're making
me look like an idiot okay aunt Andy
just just calm down this is what I put
up with every day around this circus
I'm places an amateur hour
[Applause]
hi
hello I'm Conan O'Brien and I'm here to
talk about hissy fits fitness out just
tell us what you do for a living and
hissy fit creates a real-world
frustration designed to make you lose
your [ __ ] and get your blood going no
need for a gym life is your gym you see
Andy and he's only halfway through his
workout
he's already burned 700 calories hissy
fit the hell with your family's body
hissy fit it really works
warning hissy fit apples only for older
white males society protects them from
the consequences of their childish
behavior blacks Hispanics and young
people trying to exercise like this will
get their ass beat
you